now I'm very pleased to present your
host for our next segment or hostess in
this case she's one of the leading
ladies of television who this year
became one of the leading ladies in
motion pictures here she is Tilly Miss
Carol Burnett
mr. Chuck yeah that he really is he's a
man who can do everything just in one
short period of time he led his people
out of Egypt painted the Sistine Chapel
and was elected president of the Screen
Actors Guild he also learned how to make
a hell of an entrance
once that was a very nice introduction
thank you thank you I I really did enjoy
doing Pete and Tilly this year because
it was uh it was quite a departure for
me it brought both laughter and tears
laughter in the scene when I sprayed up
Geraldine Paige's skirt with the hose
and tears when I saw Walter Matthau
naked Walter Matthau wasn't in the nude
I mean he was in the nude but in the
nude Walter wasn't the only violence in
the movies this year I saw I saw the
Poseidon Adventure and afterwards I was
afraid to take a cruise on an ocean
liner
I saw deliverance I was afraid to take a
canoe ride and then I saw Last Tango in
Paris and now I'm afraid to get in the
bathtub
believe that I did love cabaret I
thought Liza Minnelli was simply great
and I'm very happy for Joel gray I've
known Joel for many many years in fact I
knew him when his name was Joel Katz and
I think he and Liza did a fantastic job
in cabaret because it's not easy for two
kids named Minnelli and cats to
tap-dance their way across Nazi Germany
so let us proceed and now to talk about
the pictures that don't talk English the
president of the Motion Picture
Association of America mr. Jack Valenti
and a beautiful lady who speaks in acts
in six languages miss elke sommer
hi mr. Valenti and I are here to present
the award for the best foreign film of
the year now we know that the countrymen
of those filmmakers are listening and
watching just as eagerly as we are here
tonight and on behalf of the Academy may
I welcome them in their own tongue
dobriy vecher
bonsoir liftoff
buenas noches good afternoon good
evening it's right now today the movie
has no nationality
it is a citizen of the world that's
precisely right l come wherever talent
creativity and craftsmanship reside
there the movie lives in prosperous and
that's why the American film is welcomed
and viewed in more than 80 countries on
this globe because audiences look at a
film not to discover its origin but to
enjoy its content and American audiences
are no different from any other so
tonight we honor superb foreign films
created by great filmmakers from all
over the world the films nominated are
OK from the USSR as OD EST quia which
means the dawn's here or quiet rag or
key film studios production from France
l'chayim discrete del abuso AZ which of
course does mean the discreet charm of
the bourgeoisie a surge Silberman
production from Israel
Annie Oh F oh da Rosa which means I love
you Rosa
ánoá films limited production from Spain
tick me quiera de señorita
my dearest seniorita
you mean an le monde production and from
Sweden in vandana the new land Spence
film industry production right and the
winner is
right the winner is the discreet charm
of the blue I see accepting the award on
behalf of ransom the discreet charm of
the bush
Silverman
as my image is also the special visitor
short first songs to Luis buñuel did
accept it to make a victory and then I
would like to change the song to 20
Century Fox who helped people to make
the itching know especially here in the
United States
thanks to your own enter Black Adam